with infinite copies potentially of
universes what are the odds that we
would be here asking questions about our
own existence it hearkens to the very
notion of probability of choice and of
free will itself
question has parallels to the many
worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics quantum mechanics itself is
deterministic we have laws the
schrodinger equation which evolves and
has evolutionary consequences for the
behavior of particles of forces and
fields in our universe some of which may
have been instantiated in the
inflationary paradigm
by a quantum field called the inflaton
the infilton is like a rocket fuel
because like rocket fuel it's very
difficult to shut off a rocket once it's
ignited
and so too the multiverse seems
unavoidable because this scalar field
called the inflaton there are tremendous
amounts of universes being formed
without the possibility for them to be
stopped so a fundamental question that
we'll keep coming back to in this
discussion
is whether or not nature is
deterministic or not has the ultimate
impact on the question of free will if
nature is deterministic then you have no
free will quantum mechanics possesses
randomness but it also doesn't qualify
as a choice because there's no choice
there's no agent making a decision to
collapse a wave function the famous
example of schrodinger's cat and that
type of dynamics is well found to be
demonistic and yet the choice to observe
the cat comes down to a notion of an
observer's free will or not
now imagine if you had a protocol
to decide whether or not you made a
choice can you make a rubric to assess
whether or not you have free will
well if you did so by process of
elimination you could estimate that you
don't even have free will even if you
have ultimate knowledge of what's to
come in the future here's an example
imagine you're driving from los angeles
back home here to san diego you're going
down the interstate called i-5 or the
five here
and as you're going south you see the
cars coming north ground to a stop in
orange county they're at a dead
standstill because of some accident now
the people in san diego just departing
are blissfully unaware of their fate
you know their fate absolutely what
they're going to encounter
does that mean that they have no free
will we all have this elusive notion of
free will we experience it but is that
just an illusion even if the multiverse
scenario the paradigm more properly said
of the multiverse is true does that
really explain
the notion of free will that we
experience in our one observable
honest-to-goodness universe for a long
time
leading cosmologists such as stephen
hawking and alan guth envisioned our
universe as just one of countless island
universes some with constants very
different than the universal constants
that we enjoy the speed of light the
strength of gravity some with very
similar uh properties of our observable
universe there'd be outliers and there'd
be some that have just the right
goldilocks-like properties to support
life that could later ask the question
of why is our universe so particularly
finely tuned to our existence to ask the
question that i just post many
physicists find the concept of the
multiverse anathema not only to physics
but to all of science past guest paul
steinhardt has even deemed the
multiverse the ultimate compound
claiming it's not only bad for science
it's bad for society because it
undermines the notions that we have used
as a scientific method for over 400
years but what about the very notion of
choice of chance
that is underlying in a notion of what
mathematicians call the measure problem
any statistical ensemble say you have 52
playing cards in a deck of cards you can
answer the question of what are the odds
of selecting a particular card say the
ace of spades
well you can answer that because you
know the total amount of possibilities
the 52 cards that i mentioned originally
and the ace of spades just one out of 52
so you know exactly what the probability
of drawing a particular card is but in
an infinite number an ensemble what are
the odds of drawing the ace of spades
out of every possible possibility
in an infinite deck of cards with suits
unimaginable this is a problem that has
been plaguing the cosmologists that
support the notion of the multiverse
what is typical what is expected in an
infinite number of possibilities
mathematicians and physicists have been
grappling with this and it's an
interesting combination of the primitive
laws of mathematics entering into a
domain of practicality for almost a
decade now researchers have realized
that this is a vexing and important
problem to accurately predict the
expected properties of our universe the
one that we can observe we need to
figure out a way to weight the
likelihood the probability of observing
other bubbles according to the number of
observers that they contain this is
where the cosmological meets the quantum
mechanical and this is known as the
measure problem so alan guth again the
father of inflationary theory himself
and other scientists have sought to
measure
a way to gauge the probability of
observing different types of universes
and in doing so calculate the
distribution statistically of observable
bubbles so how many of each type of
universe could arise in a specific time
interval now they found a particularly
vexing sub-problem the statistical
distribution of the number of universes
depending on how scientists define time
in the first place now colleague up at
uh uc berkeley raphael busso came up
with some ways to quantify the
likelihood of observable universes
possessing observers within them in a
way that is related to the problem of
entropy they call this type of measure
an immortal watcher
this observer soars through the
multiverse counting different events
such as the number of observers
the frequency of these events in the
distribution can be converted to a
probability of observation
this then solves the measure problem
however critics point out that this is
sort of assuming something completely
implausible up front
how does this immortal watcher survive
all the different bubbles it can't be an
observer like ourselves so they compare
this as sort of an avatar that has to
persist alan guthan collaborators look
at the process that would take place of
counting the number of elements if
multiverse was really really large but
could be granulated
into discrete patches and then you could
say that these observers could inhabit
these finite little cells of the
so-called sample space as they called it
as the sample space expands approaching
but never reaching an infinite size it
would encounter different events such as
nucleosynthesis or the formation of dark
matter halos and this observer would
count these events in an infinite
hypothetical database you just made the
list according to alan guth that these
observers could see anything that could
possibly happen will happen but those
events would not all occur with equal
probability
so you could have an infinite number of
occurrences but they wouldn't occur
as likely for some scenarios as for
others so both the approach of the
immortal watcher and this fictitious
database they seem kind of far-fetched
and we seem to observe a preference for
things like protons to be the
fundamental building blocks of matter
but not some hypothetical particle my
favorite particle the crouton the
question is how could you weight the
probability of protons versus the
fictitious croutons and their
probability to be found so there's a
tremendous amount of speculation and so
it all has to come down to quantum
mechanics at some level but quantum
mechanics is just a manifestation of the
waviness the uncertain nature of matter
and energy now imagine if you will a
infinite wave train a wave that has to
go on forever that's necessary to
produce what's called a monochromatic or
monotonal acoustic wave it takes an
infinite amount of time formally
speaking to produce a single wave of
perfectly defined frequency what's
special about quantum mechanics is that
it says that matter itself is wavy it's
non-localizable
but does this really imply no free will
what does that really mean whether or
not we have free will is it based on
being able to predict the future or is
it based upon
ability to constrain present choices
what if it's not something we can
reconcile with the laws of physics with
quantum mechanics or even with the laws
of philosophy can we actually test
whether or not we have free will within
the bounds of a theory that talks about
notions of choices of quantum mechanical
effects and causes thereof so both the
many worlds interpretation and the
multiverse have things in common they
have a nexus of overlap which is this
problem of what does it really mean to
define a probability to make an event so
buso looks at this problem and he homes
in on a finite patch of the universe
that he calls the causal diamond it's
pretty cool concept and he says that
that is the largest swath accessible to
a single observer traveling from the
beginning of time if there was a
beginning to the end of time if there is
an end of time in such a causal diamond
the finite boundaries of this structure
are formed by the intersection of the
two light cones
going both forwards and backwards in
time these light cones spread out at the
speed of light if you will there are all
the things that could be influencing the
current observer from the birth of the
universe if the universe began at a
single uh moment in time called the big
bang typically and if indeed it proceeds
into the future all the events are in
the forward light cone that this
particular observer say yours truly
could influence going forward now
because of the causal diamond structure
is finite it avoids some of the
infinities and formally avoids the
measure problem since any
experimentalist only has a finite life
expectancy or even consecutive
generations of
experimentalists they can only make a
finite number of observations well if
the assumption that the experimentalists
can freely choose the conditions at will
then this is sort of a conundrum that's
going to remain how do we assess the
likelihood of probabilities in a
universe that may not be singular in our
own universe are there consequences of
the multiverse or of everett that could
be tested to give us some credulity in
the probability of existence of the
multiverse itself one of those will be
obviously observations of the cosmic
microwave backgrounds b mode
polarization with upcoming experiments
like our simon's observatory small
aperture telescopes and the recently
recommended for funding
cmb stage four project which both
happens their aim the revelation if you
will of gravitational waves produced by
inflationary expansion now that would be
a powerful harbinger of the inflationary
epoch it wouldn't prove necessarily that
the multiverse is true and there are
experiments as described by sean carroll
in his excellent something deeply hidden
that could test whether or not the
universe has this branching probability
at each moment both of these would give
more credulity to the existence of the
multiverse but for now one wonders if
the multiverse is being taken more
seriously than the investigations into
either the foundations of quantum
mechanics and the notion of what
constitutes an observer
and or whether or not the universe
actually obeys these kind of bizarre
properties of many worlds or quantum
uncertainty originating from an
incredibly energetic event in the
universe's past so for now if you've
made it this far you've shown
exceptional free will and great judgment
and i hope that you'll continue to go on
and investigate more fascinating aspects
in future episodes of into the
impossible
if you love learning about the brain
consciousness and intelligence i know
you'll love this special playlist that i
created just for you click here and
don't forget to subscribe